[موسيقى
] يلتقي رواد الأعمال في دبي
شخصيًا لأول مرة ، هل
تعتقد أن هذه ستكون أفضل طريقة للقيام
بذلك مع مجموعة المؤسسين الفلبينيين
وأصحاب الأعمال الذين قدموا لمساعدة بعضهم
البعض عبر الإنترنت
طوال فترة الوباء الطمع ،
الفكرة الرئيسية هي  المجتمعات
تدعم بعضها البعض في الواقع
، شارك بأفكارك الناشئة ، أو
تشارك بعض الإستراتيجيات ،
وآراءك تعرف ، مرحبًا ، لدي هذا المنتج ،
ما رأيك في ذلك.
مرحباً شارون ، كيف حالك صباح الخير الأيرلندي
هو مؤسس insturia ،
وهي شركة قائمة على التكنولوجيا  المطبوعات
وتسليم كتب الصور التي تم
إطلاقها في العام الماضي كانت شركتها قد بدأت
للتو عندما ضربت Covet 19
التداعيات العالمية التي كانت
مدمرة للعديد من الشركات الناشئة بما في ذلك
الأيرلندية التي تعتمد على
أحداث التواصل وجهًا لوجه للإعلان
والحصول على التمويل الآمن تقول أن هذا
المجتمع ملأها  هذا
الفراغ وساعد في الحفاظ على بدء تشغيل
ما يقرب من 10 في المائة من إيراداتها
تأتي الآن مباشرة من أعضاء المجموعة
التي فتحت أيضًا أبوابًا جديدة  الاستثمارات
وشراكات الشركات
حتى لا نقول شيئًا عن الدعم غير المادي الذي
يوفره هذا المجتمع ،
لذا فقد كان في الواقع دعمًا جيدًا
لنا
لأنك تعلم أننا لسنا
وحدنا
نقاتل هذا أم نحن أه نحن
نحاول دعم بعضنا البعض  وأنت
تعلم
تحفيز بعضنا البعض لأنك تعلم أنه
يمكننا في الواقع
تجاوز هذا الأمر ، عليك فقط
البقاء على قيد الحياة ، حيث
تعد الشبكات مكونًا رئيسيًا
للنجاح لأي شركة ناشئة ،
لذا فهي تتكيف بسرعة مع بيئة الأعمال المتغيرة
بعيدًا عن الوباء الأيرلندي و  وضع العديد من
رواد الأعمال
أمثالها الشبكات عبر الإنترنت في
صميم نشاطها التجاري ،
مما أدى إلى إنشاء مجتمع عبر الإنترنت
تعتقد أنه سيقوي شركتها الناشئة
إلى المستوى التالي John defterious
cnn
[موسيقى]